hi so hello everybody my name is even
the blaming I'm a postdoc in the lab of
Steve quake at Stanford and today I'm
going to tell you a little bit about how
we've been using DNA sequencing for the
sequencing of plasmid DNA and that is
cell free DNA or circulating DNA for the
diagnosis of simultaneous diagnosis of
rejection and infection in organ
transplantation and this work came out
of a very strong collaboration I think
we can say between our lab and several
people in at Stanford Hospital they have
an interest in in heart and lung
transplantation so but before I go into
describing the essay and talk about the
results I wanted to share some numbers
with you about organ transplants so
there's about 180,000 people living with
solid organ transplants in the US alone
there's about 2,000 heart transplants
performed every year and there's about a
thousand lung transplants performed
every year at Sanford hospital alone
Stanford is a bit of a center of
expertise when it comes to
transplantation at Stanford Hospital
there's about 60 heart transplants
performed every year and about 40 lung
transplants or querida and how all these
patients require post-transplant care
and post transplant care in the context
of transplantation is challenging and
it's challenging because these patients
face a duel risk of rejection and
infection and it's only since the early
80s with the advent of very strong
immunosuppressants that transplantation
has become a viable therapeutic option
so via immunosuppression you can might
again pretty much the risk of transplant
rejection but me knows me no suppression
or loss of immune strength and opens up
the window for new set of problems in
the face of infections and so really the
therapeutic window that is available for
treatment of these stations is very very
narrow and you can imagine that in this
context is very important to to have
very informative Diagnostics at hand but
it turns out that none of the metrics
that I've put on the axis here can be
measured faithfully
it started to say that right now there
is really no way to measure somebody's
immunocompetence or the level of a
transplantation for example or any
patient for that matter its level of
immune suppression it's of course true
that there's a lot of important that
measurements available for infection for
example molecular assays based on pcr
but most of these essays required on a
particular hypothesis for what the
source of the infection might be for
measurements of transplant rejection
also there's a lack of informative
Diagnostics I'll just show you the
example of the heart transplant in our
transplants the current gold standard
for rejection diagnosis is the end of
myocardial biopsy and the enemy cardio
biopsy is a surgical procedure in which
pieces of tissue are removed from the
transplant graft and then stained and
examined under a microscope so you can
imagine that this is a very subjective
measurement it turns out if you ask two
pathologists to grade the same bites you
slide that they will only agree in about
seventy percent of the cases it's also
an expensive procedure it's invasive
with major complications in about one
percent of the cases but nevertheless
for example at Stanford the first year
post transplant are transplants heart
transplant patients will on average on
the go ten of these biopsies in the
first here and so there's clearly a lot
of room for improvement and an
opportunity for such improvement is
found in this phenomenon of circulating
cell-free DNA cell free DNA is DNA that
is not contained within cells and is
floating around in blood it's usually
associated with histone octamer and it
is prevented from degradation by nucleus
that are abundantly present in blood
because of its because of its side
association with these proteins or
histone octamer it was already
discovered in 48 even before the
structure of DNA was resolved and that's
because it's a bomb only present in
plasma there's about 10,000 genome
copies worth of cell-free DNA in every
milliliter of blood so that means
there's about a hundred billion
fragments of DNA available for analysis
by a sequencing for example
and we have lifetime of cell-free DNA is
short 15 minutes so that means that the
turnover rate of cells must be pretty
high in order to sustain this sort of
you know steady state level of of
cell-free DNA in blood already 15 years
ago then is slow found that in the
context of organ transplantation that
there is actually donor-derived DNA
molecules circulating in plasma and he
made that observation based on sex
mismatched patients in particular female
recipients of a male graft where he
showed that there's actually chromosome
wide arrived in a floating around in
blood and already in a seminal paper he
proposed that you could use donor DNA as
a marker of rejection and the idea is
simple here the idea is that when
rejection occurs that there will be
damage to the graft and as a consequence
cells within the graft will die and
their genomes will end up in the blood
stream and so you can imagine that if
you can count the number of donor
molecules versus the number of recipient
molecules that you can come up with some
kind of metric of graphs damage in our
lab just a couple years ago proposed
this new technique that is based
genotyping that would allow to measure
the fraction of donor DNA and the
presence of donor DNA in the blood of
transplant recipients regardless of the
factor of whether the transplant
recipient is sex match for sex mismatch
with the donor and so the idea is very
simple we collect genotypes from both
the donor and the recipient
pre-transplant and then we use
sequencing of cell-free DNA to establish
the number of donor Drive DNA molecules
cost France pal and so you can imagine
that if the donor and the recipient are
homozygous at a particular position so
let's look at say position and in the
diagram here both the recipient and the
donor are homozygous and carry the C
allele our homozygous would carry a
different allele the donor cares a CEO
leland the recipient carries the a
allele so you can imagine that if you
sequence at all the plasma DNA and you
find a molecule a DNA molecule
sequence maps to position and in the
genome and you find a real see that you
can have some confidence or that you can
evaluate with some conference that that
molecule must come from the owners Gina
and we'll talk a little bit about error
rates in just a second so this is
essentially the basis of the netting so
what we've done over the last couple of
years is we've collected a lot of
samples from both heart and lung
transplant and first going to talk about
the heart transplants in heart
transplants we've recruited about 20
pediatric patients and about 45 adult
heart transplant patients and we've
collected old blood samples
pre-transplant for genotyping and then
salt free plasma DNA or plasma samples
post transplant and we purify the
plasmid DNA and sequence tip and
eventually that allowed us to evaluate
the fraction of donor-derived DNA
molecule which is the metric that we are
interested in and we compare that to the
biopsy grade and we've collected about
20 million sequences for example that
means that we've sequence about eight
samples for high C clean and there's
about 50,000 informative snips available
in the genome that means that 50,000
snips for which the donor and the
recipient are homozygous and carry a
different allele so it makes it very
straightforward to distinguish board
owner in iraq and recipient drive
molecules or sequences and about 15,000
of our sequences we do shotgun
sequencing again of the plasma DNA a
line randomly to these informative snips
and allow us to to count the owner
versus recipient molecules and one
important aspect of the essay is that
we're able to measure the error rate for
every individual sample and the way we
do that is by evaluating matched snip
pairs and that is we look for snips for
which the donor and the recipient or
homozygous and carry the same allele so
now you can imagine that a both the
donor and recipient recipient k allele a
at a particular position and you measure
by sequencing ceg or a tea at that
particular standard position that you
must have made some kind of error right
and so it's possible to evaluate the
irate and that error rate measurement
was importantly turned out to not only
exclude
samples that have suffered from high
error rate but also it allowed us to
figure out how the measurement errors
couple into our measurement signal and
allowed us to do some background
correction they on the basis of that
observation and so all of the
measurements I'll show today are
essentially measurements that have been
corrected for that measurement error
background and so the matter in that
error is actually pretty low we get it
wrong in about four out of ten thousand
cases or poor out of ten thousand
measurements but let's go to the actual
measurements I think it's most
interesting these are some first data
collect for patients that do not reject
so these are all transplant patients
about 11 I think that went on to have a
rejection free course in the first year
and so what we find is merely
post-transplant we find an elevated
level of donor DNA up to from average
since about four percent I believe of
the owner DNA on the first day post
transplant and this is likely due to
some damage related to surgery or some
loosely associated cells donor cells
that are releasing blood but then very
quickly the signal drops to a very low
background level and essentially four
recipients that do not reject we do not
measure any donor DNA however this is
quite different for transplant patients
that do reject for example this one that
goes on to have a severe rejection about
15 you can see that there's ago an
elevation in donor DNA around that time
phone and there's some other examples
for example this pediatric patient had
multiple rejection events and here we
have a transplant patient that had a
reject that rejected and required a
repeat transplant as a way to intervene
and what you can see is that the dollar
fraction decays back to a very low
baseline level after this repeat
transplant and so that indicated to us
that there's very little residual Kiner
ism and that the signal is not confused
by residual fibers and so that you can
use this test also in the context of we
transplant and we've collected many
samples and there were
several hundreds of biopsies match
fights he's available for his
measurement and we of course it signal
analysis we find that the that donor
fraction is indeed elevated at time of
rejection compared to samples that are
recorded at quiescence you'll see that
there's only very few outliers here and
most of the samples here recorded at
quiet sense for patients that do not
reject actually show very low very low
donor fraction compared to samples
collected at rejection where we see this
highly elevated donor signal you can do
a receiver operating characteristic
analysis so putting the true positive
rate versus the false positive rate as
you change the threshold for detection
and what you really care about is
essentially the area under the curve
here the greater the greater the area
under the curve the better the test and
what we find is that the area in the
curve here is about point a tree which
is much higher than the area under the
curve for another non-invasive
diagnostic that is B that is based on on
a measure of measurement of gene
expression markers in blood and an
analysis of the of the of the signal
against a biopsy indicated that a lot of
this that that the sensitivity of our
tests approaches probably approaches
that the sensitivity in the selectivity
of the gold standard and we looked at
early detection the possibility for the
potential for early detection and we
find that donor DNA signals are elevated
up to four for four or five months
before the actual rejection event we
find that the detection quality is
higher for patients that are younger and
for samples that are collected at a
later time for time point post-transfer
so then in the second project we wanted
to figure out whether this test would
also be applicable to other settings
such as for example lung transplant so
we wanted to address a question is this
is this test universally applicable is
it also applicable to other organ pipes
and other
concept and so we looked at lung
transplants and the survival rates for
lung transplantation are actually quite
a bit lower than the survival rates for
heart transplants the median half flight
time is only five years compacted ten
years in the case of our transplant and
that is due to several major
complications that arise following lung
transplantation for example as a
syndrome called bronchial litterin
syndrome which is related to the
progressive loss of lung function and is
likely due to chronic rejection becomes
an occurrence of minor rejection events
then acute rejection and of course
infections that that played the long
because the long is of course exposed to
the outside environment so again we did
something very similar than we did for
the long term for the heart transplants
we collected in this case samples mostly
from adult lung transplant recipients
fifty one of these at is at had no 44 of
these had a bilateral long term that
means that they received at both sides
of the lung and seven of these only
received a single lung transplant we
collected samples pre-transplant for
genotyping and post transplant we
collected blood samples and extracted
plasma and plasma DNA for sequencing and
these are some of the results at first
we again look at patients that do not
project defined for lung transplants
very highly elevated levels of donor DNA
needed lead post-transplant up to fifty
percent of the DNA floating around in
plasma of this transplant recipients on
the first day is actually the owner
derived and that's much higher than what
we saw for heart transplants and that
signal then quickly decays to sort of a
meet an intermediate level and then
there's the signal stays elevated for
several months and only the gates too
small to a low baseline after about 100
days so there's this 222 kinetic decay
process going on you're going on in four
lung transplants and in this in sets
we're comparing the dynamics for the
lung versus the heart and you can see
that there's much more donor-derived DNA
for once then there is four hearts it's
kind of curious it's interesting to look
at the signal for single and bilateral
lung transplants
and as you would expect we find higher
levels of donor DNA for for transplant
recipients that received the both sides
of the long vs only single side the lung
so there's a nice correlation between
transplant Matt's raft mass and the
level of donor DNA in absence of
rejection and you can then expect a
number of the turnover rate of fat cells
per second and it's actually interesting
to see that is about a hundred lung
cells that are turning over every second
that that level of turnover is required
to explain the levels of donor DNA that
we're measuring in the study of course
we also looked at the samples from
patients that ended up rejecting and we
find that there's again an elevated
level of donor DNA at a time of
rejection coinciding with this
transferring had you know rejection as
observed by the transbronchial biopsy
and the plot on the right shows this one
here shows it's actually all the data
we've collected for patients that shows
signs of clinical rejection and no signs
of clinical rejection and you can
already tell that there's an elevation
for the data that is colored red here
and here we've excluded samples
collected in the first 60 days post
transplant because we be fine even for
patients without that do not reject that
there's an elevated level of donor DNA
early on post transplant possibly
related to you know decay of the lung
that parts of the long that are not
connected to the blood circle ok so we
exclude those sample is quite in the
first two months and then do a signal
analysis and this is what comes out of
it again we find that donor DNA is
significantly elevated at at time of
rejection for patients that are mothered
that have suffered from a moderate to
severe rejected me find elevated levels
of donor DNA compared to patients that
do not show signs of rejection at least
based on this transformative biopsy and
you can again compute an ROC here and we
find that the area under the curve for
discriminating the severe rejections
from no rejections is
point nine and we went down to
congratulate other metrics and find that
there's a good correlation between graft
injury as noted by a various kinds of
measurements with non transplantation
and donut living and so the conclusions
here for now are that cell free DNA
enables the diagnosis of rejection in
transportation and that software DNA
potentially offers a universal way to
diagnose transplant rejection across all
patient groups and across all organ
pipes and we find that at least four
heart transplants and that the cell free
DNA test outperforms other existing
commercially available non-invasive
tests all right so but there are some
issues that are remaining and first of
all donor DNA is not a not informative
of over immune suppression so there's
there so this need for more informative
measurements of the level of us
aggression the other shortcoming of the
tests is that donor DNA is not
informative infection so it doesn't
discriminate between infection and
rejection related tissue damage and
there's a few examples providers can
matter for example in kidney transplants
there's often a lot of damage to the kid
need you to polio my virus that is
actively replicating in the kidney and
similar things have been noted for
infections with cytomegalovirus in the
context of lung transplantation and so
so there's I want to just wanted to
remind you of this duel risks that exist
in transplantation and so we have a
marketer's potentially informative or
rejection but it's still clear that more
work needs to be done on the infection
and so one way to illustrate this is
we've collected clinical data
essentially all the clinical data
available for these patients infections
and we found that there's an elevated
level of donor DNA at a time that CMV
infections are diagnosed you know
detected in these patients brought in
bronchial bronchial lavage samples and
in serum so when patients are positive
for CMV a political kind of herpes virus
that can cause graph damage
fine elevated levels of donor DNA so
this is a clear sign that there is
infection related tissue damage taking
place it turns out that TV is the only
organism for which we find evidence of
robust evidence for this infection
related tissue damage so this is
something that seems to be unique to cvn
and isn't a lot in line with what people
have observed in transplant literature
so but then of course if there can be
infection related tissue damage the
question is can you also diagnose
infections based on sequence data and so
what we did is we looked for CMV
cytomegalovirus related sequences in our
data sets plasma DNA data sets and we
found in need that a time of seeing the
diagnosis that you can find bits and
pieces of the genome of this particular
herpes virus and again we do a signal
analysis and we find that that there's a
good correlation between that
measurement based on sequencing and the
measurements based that are performing
in the hospital so this is just a
demonstration of the use of shotgun
sequencing for the diagnosis of a
particular kind of infection and we
looked a little bit more broadly in our
data sets into the little bit more
deeper at the nonhuman direct sequences
in our data sets and we find that about
75% of the sequences that are not human
derive are actually coming out of the
genomes of viruses and this is corrected
for genome abundance so this this is
here we're taking into account the
differences in genome sizes of viruses
and bacteria and so 75% most abundant
and viruses are most most abundantly
represented in this data set and given
that these are shotgun sequencing data
you can drill down on this at any level
of classification and so you can explore
what kind of viruses are found and we
find evidence for many different viral
families in our data set and one viral
family that is abundantly present is the
family of the analysis here indicated in
orange so this is the orange lid of the
pie again now it turns out that in l a--
viruses are commensal viruses there are
ubiquitous in human
the human population and essentially
anybody in the Western population has
been infected with this virus and we
find lots of it in a plasma of these
organ transplant recipients we also find
evidence of herpes viruses for example
CMV the example TV was already touched
upon but also polyomavirus poxviruses
adenovirus etc and also evidence of
phages was done okay given us a shotgun
sequencing data you can drill down on
this a little bit more and find down to
the strain level you can figure out what
the most likely cause these of these DNA
of these weeds or sequences are and you
can do something very similar for
bacteria I look at different levels of
classification you can look at the
different bacterial phyla and bacteria
orders that are represented in the data
set and the most interesting finding
observation from this study was that
that the virulence or the collection of
different viruses that are found in the
in the plasma of these transplant
recipients that the structure of that
volume the composition of the
environment is very strongly affected by
the immunosuppressant and antiviral
drugs and patients we see so when
patients are very strongly immune
suppressed and this is typically after
three or six months post transplant we
find a lot of these analysis so this is
the orange family here indicated in
orange in plasma and so it seems that an
alibi are particularly good at taking
advantage of laws of immune function and
this is in language but some other folks
have observed for example with HIV HIV
patients that progress towards eight
it's found that there's more and more
and a low viruses president plasma and
you can look at the time dynamics of the
volume structure and immediately post
transplant we find only a small fraction
of an aloe vera so these are the orange
guys here and there are only
representative as a minority fraction
but after three months or so
post-transplant you can see that the
analysis have completely taken over
and are now the most bumble bee
represented species after six months
post transplant so this is when the the
drug doses are are at the highest level
this is when the risk of rejection is
highest so patients are most deeply
immune suppressed after six months it's
judged that at the risk of rejection is
a little own so in a typical transplant
protocols the drug doses will be tapered
off and what you see is an immediate
response of the viral to that tapering
of the blood users and so the last
question we addressed what was whether
there's a relationship between whether
the violent structure is different for
rejecting versus non rejecting
individuals and this was basically
hypothesis that rejecting individuals
might have an immune system that is a
little bit more active is a little more
strongly functioning and so that would
mean that you would see a lower load or
lower probability of infection and
potentially lower load of various
viruses whereas patients that do not
reject may have an immune system that is
more effectively suppressed and
therefore the load of viruses might be
high so that was a simple idea and we
tested yet and we we particularly looked
at the analysis because we find it is
such a tight correlation between the
load of an olive irises and the level of
immune suppression would be fine is that
indeed the load of an alibi is allow
stratifying the rejecting versus non
rejecting individuals sewn on rejecting
individuals tend to have a higher load
of nano viruses which is in line with
this the hypothesis that non rejecting
individuals have an immune system that
is more effectively suppressed on
average and so we also then propose if
you could use a load of vanilla virus as
a marker of immune suppression and we
find that that again didn't help the
load of an aloe vera slowed silao
stratifying patients that reject that do
not reject versus severe rejecting
patients and here we find an area on the
curve of about 17 and so this bring meet
brings me to the overall conclusions and
we find that donor Drive DNA
is an informative marker graph injury in
both heart and lung transplantation and
there's some hints and we're exploring
this much deeper now the sequencing can
be used as a tool for the broad
hypothesis free diagnosis and infections
and it's interesting to look at
transferring patients in this context
because there's a lot of clinical data
on infections available to which you can
compare the data to and we find that
farmer pharmacological treatment in
particular immune suppression has a very
strong effect on the structure of the
violence or the collection of different
viruses that you find in plasma the
composition of a viral and last but not
least we find that there's a strong
interaction between immune strength and
environment structure and that the Lord
oven a love Iris's could be used as a
potential marker for components brings
me to the acknowledgments I really want
to thank all my colleagues at the quake
lap and particularly Steve quake for
being such a fantastic advisor and all
the folks at Stanford Hospital that
collaborated with us on this project
really a large diversity of people in
particular Karen question really was a
strong need of this project at the
hospital end and then last lastly I want
to say that at the end early next year
I'll be moving to Cornell to set up my
own lab and so in case there's somebody
in the audience is looking that is
looking for postdoc positions or other
kinds of positions and is interested in
this type of work or in work related to
single-cell genomics which is another
thing that I will be focusing our and
then feel free to contact me and so with
this side I'm open for questions so the
first question is from Rogan rhetoric
from Oregon and Rogan asks how large of
the panel of genes do you analyze so
it's important to point out that for the
rejection diagnosis that we use shotgun
sequencing so we're not doing targeted
sequencing of a particular G and we're
genotyping the patient across the entire
genome and
use about 1 million to 2.5 million
markers that are randomly look well that
are spread out across the genome so
we're not focusing on particular genes
here we use shotgun sequencing random
selection of sequences in the gee I hope
that answers that question are there any
other questions
so Rebecca fine asks how will your data
analysis impact future transplant
research and patients well we hope that
that our study and another related
studies will allow to improve
post-transplant care first of all
there's a need for better and more
informative markers of rejection we hope
that the number of biopsies that that
patients have to undergo post transplant
will be able to be reduced based on
based on our findings there's good hope
that the cell-free DNA test that we and
others have described in this format or
another format will be available in the
clinic within the next few years and
then outside of that we hope that the
study of the infections will allow to
for example tailored immune suppressant
dosage to the needs of a particular
patient abbas d by asks in analyzing of
genes do you focus on the importance of
epigenetics and we haven't done so and i
would be interesting to do that but we
haven't done so so right now if we
haven't looked at any epigenetic changes
or markers nicola erratic of university
of alberta asks if i followed correctly
can virum the indicative of
immunosuppressive impact of the chosen
drugs indeed yes and so we believe that
the structure of the viral the the
abundance of particular viro types can
be can be used is informative of the
level of the immune suppression of
particular patient so it's important
again to to point out that in
transplantation every transplant
recipient receives essentially the same
drug regimen but it's clear that not
everybody responds in the same way to
the same drug dosage
and that leads to the that leads to over
immune suppression or under immune
suppression for many of the transplant
patients and the hope is that by
measurements of for example the
structure of the viral or other
measurements that we're working on that
it will be possible to Taylor the tailor
the drug therapy to the needs of the
patient so tweaked the drug the
immunosuppressive dosage to base on the
observed level of immune competence of
the transplanted alright so any more
questions if not I would like to thank
the audience and wish you all a good day
right